i propose
thanks to the organic organizers and to
rajci
i propose three topics and they choose
the most difficult to say in 20 minutes
so let's start this is a
promise but we have
few minutes to pro to visit all the
topics
maybe we can start quick
artificial intelligence is a broad term
at a time that is has decays of history
accumulating every tools
every algorithms every new things
you can talk about artificial
intelligence
for example in in the initial phases
of initial years of artificialization
the idea is was more hard than today
is to produce software and ancient
that are intelligence her intelligence
but the history moves apps
to different tools
that are the case most of these tools
have has the case of history but now are
again as a hot topic for example
two topics that we will explore today is
genetic algorithms and neural networks
but at the end i want to
to add some critique to this
fashion in artificial intelligence
something to to read in the bathroom for
example
you you got with this book to the bottom
open the page
and something that is interesting
you will find you will find yes
okay this is artificial intelligence a
modern approach
the norwich russia
russia and norway i don't know well
this is the the book i read for this
talk
one thing that was at the initial
of the history of artificial intention
was to produce board games in an
intelligent way
people of my generation oh i am so old
i wrote pronouns using punching cards
yeah it's true using mbcd in the ibm
frameworks
but maybe you know this
movie where games where
a computer play board games
simulated board games when you play
games you need to evaluate your moves
possibly you need to evaluate a visit
branch of a tree in different search
algorithms
at the at the beginning of the 80s one
one program defeated a world champion
in backgammon yes it was
a work from hans berliner that is was
the
world champion of male chess
and a team so
i i have a demo sorry
about research but this demo i will skip
this demo
because it's all working progress but
this demo is
still it has another approach
to evaluate visiting all the branches of
the trees
instead of having heuristic like the
hansberliner
work this demo is start to
visit all the tree in the backgammon
with the evaluation of the other
position
using a metric how many
cells are far of the end of the game for
each color
but the problem with this demo
is that this is still too slow
i plan to add distributed nodes
to parallelize the evaluation of the
tree
more interesting is to use genetic
algorithms
the genetic algorithms again
has the case of history but the idea is
to have
a population of genotypes that are
maybe um represent a solution of a
problem
and the genotype can be mutated
and can be cross over each other to
generate a better population solving
the same problem for example
at the beginning you create a population
of phenotypes
you evaluate f genotype output
select the best genotype the best
individuals and mutate them for the next
generation
in this demo you can create
this is for the browser and for notice
yes you can create
the the population
to resolve one problem
and then you can add to the population
the mutator who you choose to
evolve to apply evolution to the
population
and you in each population you can
choose the better
individuals let's go to run this example
oh sorry i am the guy using windows
yeah i am
yes this is a secret a secret program
called dos alignus
clone from i am microsoft mvp
but this is under nda i don't know non
disclosure agreement
i need to to raise your memory after the
talk
well the problem
is to generate a path from one corner to
other corner
that dots are stones i am not stones
are dots but you can see that there are
stones and then each genotype
could be a path but the path
could have different evaluation
depending
if the paths go through a stone or not
and the distance of the path that from
one
corner to another instead of generating
one genotype by time i can run
a population
oh sorry it's not working
oh it's okay
oh in english too he's working man look
at
hey i can't stop
and get the guests genotype
is this path i could create
another war
and then explore the population
and get the best genotype and so on
okay this is a
a short demo let's go
in other networks there is the one thing
that
the genetic algorithm has is that the
the genetic gallery
don't don't know about the problem
only generate a solution by
trying neural networks can be trained
an artificial network can is a
an artifact that has input the input has
weight and the weights are some
summit i don't know and the the
the total of the input are evaluated
without an output for the artificial
negro
you can put many layers of artificial
network and the artificial network can
be trained
you adjusting automatically the weight
of one layer to another layer
there is a demo that is has few lines
you can create a network with the the
layers
in this case in the first line you
create a network with three layers
and you can
train the network using
the the input and the expected output
job is for example this demo
the
there are these sheets i could i can
create a network
and evaluate if this is this is
the pronunciation in english i don't
know
and the output are three outputs or
recognize
a zero a one or a two
the first network produce garbage
but you can train network
and then notice that the network starts
to recognize the zero start to recognize
the one
and start to recognize the
the two digits and you can try
more times and so on now
actually there are better
implementations for example
com neb net say yes that
using a database or data set of
handwritten digit
start to recognize a trinet in different
ways
in different ways recognize
hand-written digits
and notice that is very good in the
in the training this this particular
library is using something more than
neural networks
something that they call deep learning
because they are using new algorithms to
train
more fast faster a neural network
for example it can train it can be
trained
to recognize image
in the browser or notice yes
but this is not so good unless for the
first iteration
you need more time but you know
that google and other and other
enterprises are using
fast graphics cpus i don't know how to
say
that can be trained can be used
in accelerated hardware to train neural
networks you
don't need to use only javascript
let's go
sorry
and the last live demo is something that
i like
personally personally i like oh english
is the same
in two ways is that do
you have an evil approach to generate
programs
instead of genotypes what is an
evolutionary world
um
you have a wall full of grass
the green is the grass
and you have animals predators
that can take food from the gas
the predators that has has
a random program that say oh
something in with some way you can eat
if something is random is that number
you can move to the left or and so on
the behavior of each of the animals is
controlled by
a random program that can be modified
using genetic
algorithms then the red
animals are the good ones and the black
animals has few energy
now run a new generation
now are more red animals because they
they select the best animals in the
first generation and generate
new animals that notice that
there are few grass now because the
animals now are have
better problems to to eat and to move
in the in the world and you have
better programs
and better problems each program
each population is generated a base
genotype
but this is a problem not notably
a notable javascript at least can modify
its own structure you can modify the
program
in javascript generate a new program
okay that is the
the end
but what is the problem with all this
approach
is a soft artificial intelligence
no baby needs to see
1000 pictures of a cat
to recognize a cat no
no of this no of this algorithm
knows has knowledge about the domain
they attack there are only
algorithms we need to explore
like in the initial years of artificial
intelligence
we need to explore the hard way of
artificial intelligence
one thing that we need to do is to
create
really an intelligent agent that can be
not played in
in toy worlds but in a real world
not in a in a simulated world
but the real world this is an image
about image but it's an image for the
the book
the artificial intelligence another
approach
the idea is to have an intelligent agent
or maybe an artificial life
agent you you don't need to to pursue
all intelligence in one piece in one
step maybe the step is to have
a nation that is an artificial life
asian instead of having all the
knowledge all the
all the intelligence we have as human
one thing to explore them it's not both
unrelated things that really
works in real environment not in
simulated environment
oh i i am problem
in my voice okay that is
the idea of the talk all the resources
the demo the project and the
and the different things i read
are in the in this github
rep thanks